working on television can be a great
experience but some actors end up with
serious misgivings about particular
shows on which they appeared
from teen stars to legendary comedians
there are a whole lot of actors who
seriously regret playing in certain tv
shows
when misha barton took on a lead role on
the teen soap the oc
she was already a star in the making the
show chronicled the lifestyles of the
rich and famous in southern california's
orange county
as marissa cooper the rich beautiful and
troubled girl next door barton strikes
up a relationship with brooding outsider
ryan atwood
played by ben mckenzie becomes friends
with seth cohen and summer roberts
played by adam brody and rachel bilson
and deals with school
drinking problems and plenty of ups and
downs with her dramatic and difficult
parents
barton left the show during its third
season after her character was killed in
a car crash
she later admitted that if she could do
it all over again she probably wouldn't
have taken the role though mackenzie
brody and bilson were firmly in their
20s during their time on the oc
barton was just 17 when she started and
in retrospect she said
people say be grateful for what you have
but it was certainly
not the kind of thing i was expecting it
to be
mandy patinkin has been one of the most
recognizable faces in hollywood for
decades but before his long-running role
on showtime's homeland alongside claire
danes
he had a few botched stints on
television
appearing on both chicago hope and
criminal minds for just two seasons
before leaving both shows
as far as chicago hope was concerned
potenkin simply wanted to be able to
spend more time with his family and
couldn't handle the schedule but
criminal minds was a different matter
patinkin signed on to play jason gideon
a criminal profiler with a dark past
but he ended up exiting the series just
two episodes into the third season
due to creative differences which is a
polite way of saying he hated the
material potinkin told new york magazine
that he was shocked by the show's gory
disturbing content
saying i thought it was something very
different i never thought they were
going to kill and rape all these women
every night
every day week after week year after
year
it was very destructive to my soul and
my personality
after that i didn't think i would get to
work in television again
potenkin even went so far as to call the
show his biggest public mistake mincing
no words about his biggest career regret
during the height of game of thrones
which ended its run as one of the most
lauded and watched series of all time
most actors probably would have given
anything for the chance to kill
or be killed in westeros in fact plenty
of performers wound up with stints on
the show which was famous for brutally
murdering its characters
in unexpected ways however it seems as
if at least one actor who spent five
seasons in the seven kingdoms would
rather have not visited the realm
at all stephen delane played stannis
baratheon
brother of the late king robert and
seemingly rightful heir to the throne
however after trying to fight every
obstacle in his path he falls in battle
at the hands of brienne of tarth
played by gwendolyn christie after going
so far as to burn
his own young daughter at the stake as a
war sacrifice
ultimately it turns out delane might
have been just as tortured as the
character he played
he had trouble understanding the
storylines relying on co-star liam
cunningham who played davos
seaworth to explain them even after his
time on thrones delane claimed he would
turn on the show
only to turn it back off again because
he was unable to follow it proving this
notoriously complex series was even
mysterious to some of the actors
involved
when nbc's new sitcom community
premiered in 2009 the cast was a
promising bunch from future atlanta star
donald glover to the hangovers ken
jung to allison brie who would go on to
appear in mad men and glow
plus there was a former saturday night
live star chevy chase who was best known
for his series of national lampoon films
chase infamously parted ways with snl on
negative terms
so it may have been a calculated risk to
give him a role in something as small
as community and in the end it might not
have been the right call
chase stuck it out on community for four
seasons despite several high-profile
tiffs with the show's creator dan harmon
but he never missed the opportunity to
criticize the show in public
telling the huffington post that signing
onto the series was a big mistake
and that as a sitcom the entire project
was the quote
lowest form of television it's no wonder
chevy quit in the middle of the fourth
season by walking off the set
before adult animated series like bojack
horseman
archer and big mouth started to push the
envelope on dirty boundary-breaking
animation there was south park the
original controversial cartoon
no topic was untouchable for creators
matt stone and trey parker
who brought the insane raunchy colorado
town of south park to life with absurd
voice acting heightened situations and
topical references
however one longtime performer on the
show eventually hit his limit
quitting suddenly over a joke that he
thought went way too far
a 2005 episode of south park that
relentlessly skewered scientology
apparently angered isaac hayes a public
scientologist who played chef on the
show
i'm not the reincarnation of l ron
hubbard and
scientology is just a big fat global
scam
at first hayes didn't seem too upset
saying it was all in good fun
but his attitude changed because in
early 2006 hayes issued a statement
saying the show had finally gone too far
citing quote religious intolerance hayes
was released from his contract
but after his passing in 2008 his son
isaac hayes iii
said his father actually suffered a
stroke before that statement was issued
and someone involved with the church of
scientology quit
on his behalf providing a much more
tragic twist to this story than anyone
could have anticipated
the brady bunch trafficked in feel-good
humor and easy goofy jokes
an ensemble cast by nature everyone is
familiar with the story of a man named
brady his wife carol and their sons and
daughters all adjusting to life in a
much bigger family
it was sweet and sappy but according to
the guy who played mike brady the show
could have been
a lot more clever in its execution
robert reed was a classically trained
actor who even attended london's famous
royal academy of dramatic art
the man spent most of his early career
as a shakespearean actor so it's not
surprising that he was unhappy with the
brady bunches material
reed frequently clashed with the show's
producer sherwood schwartz a veteran of
the much sillier gilligan's island and
he would give schwartz unsolicited notes
before flat out refusing to appear in
the show's final episode
as the story goes schwartz wanted to
give reed the axe if the show continued
alas it didn't the brady bunch was
canceled after five
seasons child stars often work to shed
their squeaky clean images as they move
towards adulthood but
few performers have worked harder at
this than miley cyrus
after making her name on disney
channel's hannah montana where she
played a teen girl who's secretly a pop
star cyrus pivoted hard in the post
hannah years making a name for herself
as a controversial and unpredictable
artist
despite her often ridiculous antics
cyrus's undeniable talent has kept her
in the cultural lexicon
and she has said the role definitely
caused some mental challenges but
perhaps that made her who she is today
though miley cyrus says she doesn't
completely regret the show her father
billy ray cyrus who appeared on the show
as miley's father has a totally
different take
in 2011 the achy breaky heart singer
told gq that the show destroyed his
family and that he wished the series had
never happened saying quote
i take it back in a second and that
makes sense considering that he just
split up with his wife and wasn't
speaking to miley at the time
in recent years however it appears that
father and daughter have patched things
up
i just don't want you to die alone dad
the jonas brothers made up of kevin joe
and nick became superstars thanks in
part to the disney channel and original
movies like camp rock
but the brothers have some serious
regrets about their disney channel
series
starting in the spring of 2009 the three
starred in their own show
jonas renamed jonas la in its second and
final season
presenting a fictionalized version of
their lives as a boy band
when jonas la didn't continue past its
second season
it was clearly a huge relief for all
three jonases
in 2013 joe told vulture it just ended
up being some weird slapstick humor that
only a 10 year old would laugh at
we went along with it at the time
because we thought disney was our only
real shot
and we were terrified that it could all
be taken away from us at any moment
apparently all three brothers agreed in
2019 in their amazon documentary chasing
happiness they again admitted they
regretted jonas l.a with nick saying the
show was quote just a bad move
and kevin revealing that the series
definitely wasn't quote
on brand this show was not good
it didn't feel like it was us anymore
the jonas brothers have survived and
thrived in the years since but clearly
they don't spend much time
re-watching episodes of jonas l.a
lost remains one of the biggest
television hits but one of its stars had
a less than positive experience
evangeline lilly who starred as kate
austin for the show's entire run
revealed in a july 2018 episode of the
lost boys podcast that not only was she
unhappy with kate's character arc
but that she was often miserable on set
here's lily on the lost boys talking
about her character
in the beginning she was kind of cool
and then as the show went on i felt like
she became more and more
predictable and obnoxious to make
matters worse lily even detailed some
instances of sexual harassment and
coercion on set when it came to scenes
that required various states of undress
she said in season 3 i'd had a bad
experience on set with being basically
cornered into doing a scene partially
naked
and i felt i had no choice in the matter
i was mortified and i was trembling
and when it finished i was crying my
eyes out however when confronted with a
similar situation in season 4 she
bravely spoke up
i then said that's it no more you can
write whatever you want
but i won't do it i will never take my
clothes off on this show again
and she didn't lily is an mcu superhero
now
but for one dark moment lost left her
feeling powerless
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one